hi there I'm Bert it armours and this is
our why are the Otto doing this for me
[Music]
if it's autocomplete can I just not do
this change the world Wow
well Sesame Street changes the world by
showing people the best in every one of
us and he's helping us being smarter
stronger and kinder point how much just
thinks that Sesame Street makes people
happy and spread your we all about
kindness about being kind to everybody
even this lady who in not see your face
how does one get to Sesame Street I
thought this was gonna be a question
really for the count are you coming from
the east or from the West it makes a big
difference
take the art to Steinway get out walk
down the block and there you are
I personally started a new little tunnel
area right to my fairy garden Amol
helped me I think one way is to be very
generous and cooperate with other people
you know and then you can just find your
way to Sesame Street
because Sesame Street has a way of
attracting those kind of people Bert
that is very the answer I think I I
think people were just wanting to know
like you know basic directions
Oh uber maybe someone should write a
song about it what's this one how does
the Sesame Street song go okay can you
tell me how to get how to get to Sesame
Street that's how the Sesame Street song
goes it's the beauty hit you should
download it how does Sesame Street get
celebrities how do we get celebrities
mmm Facebook I just always thought that
they were on Rosita
cellphone they just kind of drop out of
the sky people in our neighborhood yeah
and I also sings that big bird
I saw the contacts in his cell phone we
also have a really good talent booking
department what is Big Bird name in
Spanish oh that's easy it's Pajaro
Grande what is Big Bird's address on
Sesame Street oh I live in my nest near
one two three Sesame Street
what's Big Bird's real name Big Bird or
Big Bird what species is Big Bird well
I've been told that I'm a lark Oscar
says that I'm I'm part homing pigeon but
but I think I'm the biggest canary 'us
look it up what is big bird's favorite
snack well you know I love birdseed
milkshakes
yeah mr. Hooper used to make them for me
at Hooper's store and now Allen makes me
birdseed milkshake Oh yummy did Cookie
Monster
change to veggie monster we heard this
all the time no me Cookie Monster once
and for all
me Cookie Monster be not Brussels
sprouts monster me not spinach monster
me Cookie Monster can we put end to this
vicious rumor next question sorry we got
a little carried away
does Cookie Monster eats real cookies of
Cormack Cookie Monster you think me get
a fake cookie no meat real cookies a
meal of chocolate chippies did my
favorite does Cookie Monster eat
vegetables we do but we still Cookie
Monster me not veggie maturity that work
misconception happened me love all kinds
of food but me love cookies but me get
vegetables be healthy monster does
Cookie Monster have a nose we know you
know can see it but we do have nose it's
way down deep in the fur see me use me
little tiny nose to smell cookies how
does the count laughs where is the
lightning
where is the Thunder what is the counts
favorite number oh that is easy it is
seven no twelve now 26
oh it is so difficult I have so many
favorite numbers how many fingers does
the count have let's count them one two
three four five six seven eight eight
fingers all together is the count from
Sesame Street a vampire
yes but I am a vampire with an
unquenchable thirst for numbers whoo how
old is the count from Sesame Street I am
six million five hundred twenty three
thousand seven hundred twenty eight
years old next October is Sesame Street
real my friends I think the answer is
obvious okay you did you wouldn't be
watching us answer these questions if it
wasn't real right in the sixth borough I
believe well Sesame Street is everywhere
it's also in our heart Oh as a matter of
fact there's Sesame Street all over the
world I forgot
Sesame Street's the longest street in
the whole wide world all right all right
let's get this over with
who is Oscar the Grouch named after I'm
named after my uncle Philip Luiz Oscar
the Grouch's best friend well I don't
really have a best friend but I am kind
of close to this worm his name is slimey
who is Oscar the Grouch his girlfriend
are you talking about grunge Etta yeah I
like to argue with her a lot if that's
who you're talking about
all right so we're done here huh what a
couple more oh come on you gotta be
kidding me
does al
have ears what does Elmo have ears
no does Elmo have a last name does Elmo
have a tail does Elmo have parents who
does a person holding card why we not
see you face is Gogi monster still on
Sesame Street
we got the rent controlled apartment me
not going anywhere is Kogi Monster going
away like vacation Cookie Monster's
there's an S his Cookie Monster's real
name Sid actually it is me real name SID
monster be intrigued by this person his
Cookie Monster here we go again
with the veggie monster what we have to
say in this world to convince people
that be Cookie Monster what what we have
to lay D what we have to do what is
Cookie Monster's will we just we just
got it SID well I want you to know that
I really enjoyed working with you this
has been really wonderful and I hope
that someday people will get to see your
face you are to come to Sesame Street
come on let's go dum dee dum dum dum you
got Google Maps